pourquoi ce qu'on pressent inventel test
[Musique]
francis est ce que vous jouez parfois de
la guitare à quatre heures du matin dans
un arbre ouais tout va bien alors aussi
il fait incroyable jeu ça te fait rire
mais est ce que je vis nana maire
adjoint didier ça te fait sans déconner
ça te fait rire mais ça les guider
pourquoi ça te fait rire c'est mon
équipe parce que t'es bon francis est ce
que vous avez déjà eu envie de mettre
votre sexe dans un trou pour faire
l'amour avec la terre et coûteux après
avoir chanté dans l'arbre
paco rabanne la fille de robert faulcon
rabat un bon coup le très beau temps a
priori j vous avez pensé quoi que
maintenant tu me donnes l'idée pourquoi
pas mais bien un copain à moi qui a fait
la caf et la guerre d'algérie il l'a
fait il a mis sa vie d'une termitière
et qu'après plusieurs guerres fin pleine
guerre en fait il a fait plein de guerre
il m'a raconté que les cactus c'est top
pour ça oui enlève les épines et puis
après ça la consistance delà de ce que
l'on doit fréquenter
quand on vient quand on fréquente la
réponse à ceux qui font l'amour dans la
terre c'est parce qu'il ya une taupe a
signalé ci est ce que vous vous est déjà
pris pour quelqu'un d'autre
oui pour moi très bien à temps
excuse-moi excuse moi est ce qui se voit
depuis tout à l'heure j'ai envie de
faire ça excuse-moi excuse moi excusez
moi et didier voilà oui c'est important
ouais parce qu'il est trop loin et
chaque fois j'ai envie de le faire
j'avais envie depuis tout à l'heure si
c'est ce que vous pensez que ce sont
tous les autres qui sont fous moi je moi
je pense pas que les gens soient plus
fou que je pense qu'on est tous fous ou
quoi mais il y en a qui le savent et
d'autres qu'ils savent pas si vous
personnellement excusé déjà parlé à un
caillou
quand je réponds à tes questions oui et
tu travers des juges mais il ya des
cailloux super sympa super est-ce que
vous avez déjà vu une soucoupe volante
oui enfin ça se précise
non mais enfin moi je sais pas ce que
c'est ce que j'ai vu mais j'ai vu un
truc dans le ciel vert comme ça avec des
sortes de huglo on était 16 sur la plage
en espagne et on n'avait rien vu
on avait beaucoup filmé par qui
s'explique de le crédit suisse
si vous êtes déjà cru que la france
pouvait à nouveau gagner la coupe du
monde de foot oui c'était répondu tout à
l'heure c'est le même soir vous l'avez
fait mais rené c'était de l'air de bleu
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu envie de
vous épiler le corps intégrer un an
jamais non jamais j'arrive enfin poils
sur le corps alors en revanche alors
j'essaie de faire pousser là mais c'est
un vieux délire d'avoir un peu de poids
ce qui va être un animal en fait ce
qu'il faut savoir et francis et qu'il
aimerait être un animal comme il peut
pas être un animal cheval non et
l'animal tu voudrais être un baffie
est ce que j ai déjà parlé avec des
morts ouais je peux répondre à sa place
ouais ouais déjà ouais regarde là ça
fait un quart d'heure que je parle ouais
avec toi je parle avec un mort c'est ça
oui c'est carolis quittent la vie mais
non non non non je veux dire que on est
tous en train de mourir là ah ouais
voilà est-ce que vous pensez que les
dauphins par an mais peuvent guérir du
cancer
les dauphins est ce que tu es et ce que
tu sais ce que les dauphins qui sont les
dauphins n'ont pas les deux façons des
loups a qui sont revenus à la mer et
quand tu dis c'est qu'un dauphin tu vous
retrouve les les pattes du loup dans les
nageoires les 32 dents du luff
voilà et c'est qu'on y avait un compte
qui s'appelait pierre et les dauphins
mais ça avait eu moins de succès est-ce
que vous avez des toques comme insulter
tout le monde portait des cuissardes
sortir des disques sortir des disques
zij à penser que vous étiez le nouveau
bob dylan avec du style en plus bien sûr
ouais mais alors le bob dylan alors un
hacker amour donnez-moi ggg dire la prod
que j'ai arrêté de tourner si on me
donnait pas l'adresse de ton divers quoi
glitter et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu